>> By asking this question- of whether the
Obama Administration will improve the state
of the world. We're implicitly saying we have
great expectations. The Obama Administration
will make the world a better place. On that
I have to give a resounding yes.
>> [girl in front of camera chanting "Obama,Obama.
Obama! Obama!]
>> The answer is no way. No! Because Obama
is the goat.
>> Well I think that he already changed the
world in 2008. Being the first colored person
to be elected President of the United States.
Me myself being Asian-American. I feel more
comfortable about him. My future generations.
If not this generation. You know three generations
from now we might see an Asian president or
Latino. Don't matter. You know he's broken
the status quo for presidency.
>> The Obama Administration. Hope for the
better? You bet! The fact that he just happens
to be a Black man will change the way that
people view our country forever.
>> I'm really serious when I walking around
talking about how Americans are being perceived
different over seas. My buddy here just said
it what I consider very poetically is that
we're in a situation now where you know what?
People are going to look at the world a little
bit different. [man laughing in background]
Barack Obama is not for Black, he's not for
White, he's not for red, blue, green. He's
for everybody.
>> First off he will definitely change this
country. Obviously he's gonna change America.
Mostly because his policies are so different
from President Bush's. Obviously the way that
he'll do things, the way he'll run. Some of
the laws that will be enacted in his time
in office. The country will change. Now, for
the same reason I believe that he will also
change the world.
>>I hope that Mr. Obama will succeed in change
outside to Red States and also succeed in
changing the way we are looking towards the
United States and it's (inaudible).
>> I do believe that Obama can bring change
in this world. If he stays committed to that
same value that brought him the Presidency.
That value of a genuine person.
>>Obama has this unique and the team behind
because it's a full team. Has this unique
opportunity um to, to make a difference because
people trust him.
>> Obama is not alone because. He has cabinet.
he his team, and he has all the supporters
around the world. It's not just about him.
It's the world.
>>When Obama said " Yes, We Can." He didn't
say "Yes, I can" He said "We". And that's
we the people.